[Musique]
où s'en vont les feuilles d'automne les
ballons les vies perdues
et les petits bateaux de papier
naviguant dans un filet d'eau ne les
cherchez pas ne les cherchez plus ils
sont déjà loin mes amis
[Musique]
ce sont là de petits malheurs qui ne
serait pas arrivé aux enfants du
moyen-âge instant là en effet l'eau
circulaient dans les rues comme un
ruisseau de campagne sans tricher ni
disparaître tout à coup dans de grands
trous noirs
les ménagères laborieuse lavaient leur
linge dans les rues au hasard des
flaques de pluie ou destination de
fontaine
aujourd'hui à l'abri d'impressionnants
tuyaux l'eau est devenue prisonnière
invisible et disciplinés
[Musique]
c'est jacqueline et toi mon petit
christophe qu'en dessous de ce trottoir
où vous jouer à la marelle circulent
tout un réseau de ruisseaux et des
rivières
[Musique]
ces cours d'eau comme les autres ont
leurs maris niais et leurs gardes il
vous intrigue n'est ce pas
jusqu'au bout d'île descendre ainsi
très loin très profond sous la ville le
long de mystérieux tunnel
peut-être jusqu'au bout du monde
[Musique]
ces dons là que vous l'êtes aller ce
beau petit bateau blanc pour y naviguer
en paix sans doute vers je ne sais quel
rivage
voici un grand collecteur celui de
bièvre qui rassemble la plus grande
partie des eaux sales de la rive gauche
[Musique]
ces zones chemine pas seul sous les
mêmes galerie passe une quantité de fils
télégraphique et téléphoniques les tubes
pneumatiques les conduites d'eau potable
et non potable et les canalisations
d'air comprimé
[Musique]
derrière ses barreaux de fer l'eau coule
coule sans cesse
[Musique]
en portant les pauvres bateaux qui se
sont sauvés pour toujours
voici un des rares égouts existantes au
xvème siècle
autrefois toute cette eau se déversait
dans la seine en nombreux petits
affluents et là souriait
[Musique]
il n'en est plus de même aujourd'hui
c'est seulement lorsque menace un
violent orage que ces étranges rivière
mais leurs flots à ceux du fleuve
[Musique]
ce large tout circulaire est destiné au
passage de la boule de curage du siphon
de la concorde car le collecteur de
bièvre que nous avons vu tout à l'heure
passe sous la scène comme le métro dans
un gros tuyau
cette boule a pour mission de récurer ce
grand tuyau elle en chasse le sable et
la boue elle met 8 minutes environ pour
effectuer la traversée d'une rive à
l'autre du fleuve
[Musique]
si l'exploration vous tente cette carte
vous permettra de circuler sans vous
perdre dans les grands chemins des
égouts long de 2000 km vous serez très
précisément de souk el quartier vous
vous trouvez sous quelle rue sous quel
immeuble
[Musique]
par l'intermédiaire du siphon que nous
venons de voir ces eaux sont acheminés
vers le grand collecteur d'asnières les
terrains qu'elle irrigue sont aménagés
en sion ce sont des champs d'épandage
c'est large bassin tranquille comme des
vasques de jardins servent à assainir
les eaux polluées des égouts
[Musique]
les eaux ainsi traités fertilise les
terrains et peuvent enfin être rejetée
sans danger dans la seine
lorsque nous nous promenons dans les
rues de la capitale
songeons quelquefois ses hommes c'est
grâce à leurs efforts constants c'est
grâce à leurs obscurs et dangereux
labeur que paris peut s'enorgueillir de
son ordre et de sa bouche
[Musique]